saudi arabia's energy ministry says an
oil tanker delivering cargo was hit by a
boat full of explosives
at jeddah port let's describe the
incident as a terrorist attack
the shipping company hafnia said its bw
orion vessel was hit by an unidentified
external source that caused an explosion
and a fire
it comes after another tanker was
damaged by a mine off the coast
last month that attack was blamed on
yemen's houthi rebels
andres kriegs an assistant professor at
the defense studies department at king's
college london he's joining us now
it's good to have you with us as always
andreas um put this into some sort of
context for us or
is the timing significant in this
absolutely i mean the greater regional
context is obviously
united states versus iran and the
maximum pressure campaign where the
iranians are trying to break out
um but i think we we shouldn't confuse
this with this wider
regional context and kind of look at the
conflict in yemen as the
as the local context between saudi
arabia and the houthis
obviously the saudis weren't out they
wanted out of this conflict for the last
year now obviously pressure is mounting
with the new biden administration as
well
for the saudis to leave this conflict um
and the saudis are probably more willing
than ever to make concessions in this
conflict to get out of
what is a protracted conflict that they
don't know they cannot win
the problem now is what is the role of
the houthis in the in in negotiations to
come what is the role of the houthis in
the future yemen and i think the houthis
are trying to double down
pressure on saudi arabia we've seen a
variety of different attacks against
saudi
um coming from yemen mostly by the hudis
in in the last month you know missile
attacks as well as mine attacks
and this one is just seems to be just
another one of these attacks
against you know targets which are very
vital for saudi arabia you know as the
greatest exporter of oil in the world
um you know the babal mandev strait and
the the waters of the red sea are
absolutely crucially important for the
oil price
and the the delivery of millions of
barrels of oil every every day so if you
make this unsafe
um that will have an impact on saudi
arabia security and that is
a very very high target and that
increases the urgency
for saudi arabia to do something about
this yemen conflict yeah and because
this is a high target and as we
mentioned of course before there have
been previous attacks there are going to
be questions aren't there
about the level and efficacy of security
in that region
right and there's quite a lot of
speculation here so the saudis have
admitted that it was an explosive
loading boat or vessel that was
basically charged against this old
tanker which suggests it was a very much
a low-tech
low-skill kind of job which is something
that the houthis can do without external
support
but the question that rises then is if
you know obviously this is a high target
and you know the the the
uh the jetta port is obviously a very
very high security risk
or a high security target then you would
make sure um that obviously this port is
adequately secured and it's kind of in
the current context kind of surprising
that the saudi
uh authorities have not had it better
under control and made sure that
something this cannot happen because if
an external
vessel can come inside the port and
actually attack while
a tanker is being uh unloaded um this is
obviously
um this should not or must not happen so
that suggests then that possibly this
might have been an external
uh um a device of of a different type
like the ones that we've seen last year
uh being used against uh targets off the
coast of uh fujian saudi
in the united arab emirates where again
it was
most most likely iranians uh and iranian
mines that
that were glued on and stuck on to the
outside of these vessels and then
exploded if it was one of these
sort of attacks executed by iranians
directly that is something that i can
see
the saudis being unable to deter and
actually
to deal with at the moment but if it is
actually this kind of low skilled
uh boat being driven into the port and
then exploded
that is something that saudi authorities
should have should have better under
control
andreas craig always good to have you
and al jazeera to give us the benefit of
your experience and
expertise we appreciate it thank you
very much indeed
thank you